Adam Cushman, Actor/Filmmaker/Author: Okay,
cry now.
Now you’re going to cry.
Ready…cry.
Film Courage: What are five things a director
should never do on set?
Adam: Yell.
Film Courage: Unless it’s “Action!”
Adam: Yeah but even that, do you need to yell
it?
Are you going to rattle the actors right before
they’re supposed to act?
I don’t know, I’m all about the quiet
action.
Line readings, don’t do that.
Just be specific with the actors.
Be like “Okay, cry now.
Now you’re going to cry.
Read…cry.”
Give them something.
Explain the situation.
Actors want you to explain the situation to
them rather then give them the result.
I think that’s key.
Don’t over shot list.
That’s another thing.
In the beginning you tend to do that and you
really want to know like the main thing is
I’m going to show up and I want to know
what I am doing and I want everyone to see
that I’ve got my stuff together and you
tend to overcompensate with the shot list
but you’ve got to let go of that.
I don’t even do it anymore because I found
the best way for the way I work is to come
in, let the actors do their rehearsal and
then block it and block according to what
they do and you will still find that it’s
similar to what you envisioned.
You are not like “Okay we are going to do
a close-up, medium close-up, over the shoulder
, around the side, master shot, four takes
of that for which you will never use.”
You know what I mean?
And doing that it makes your day go faster
as well and it’s just better for everyone.
So that’s three?
Film Courage: Do you storyboard?
Adam: I don’t know how to draw.
I wish I knew how to draw.
I would.
But no, I’ve never done that.
Film Courage: So…three…okay.
But it sounds like you feel out a lot of situations
intuitively and so you don’t always necessarily
plan things?
Because things are going to change all the
time on a film set.
All sorts of stuff is going to happen.
People are going to not show up.
Maybe they show up and they’re having a
bad day.
All different things are going to happen.
Adam: Right.
Right.
I mean plan but leave room to work so you
are in the flow.
Question For The Viewers: What are three things
a director should never do on set?